[Music]
[Music]
a very good morning to you it's seven
o'clock you're watching the only
breakfast show
live from westminster now what's the
state of racial equality in britain
well this morning we'll discuss the
things we know so far from the review
ordered by the prime minister amid last
year's black lives matter protests
the author of what white people can do
next emma de beery joins us at half past
seven
and at five past eight we'll speak to
conley olalode a co-opted member of the
commission
behind the report also this morning the
twelve-year-old boy
whose teacher made him a robotic arm
to mimic his hero iron man for just
30 pounds looking forward to that one
and at quarter to 10 the irish pop twins
jedward on why they've shaved off
those famous quilts it is wednesday
the 31st of march racial equality in
britain
we examine the findings of a major
review which recommends
longer school days for disadvantaged
pupils and ditching
the bame acronym all this could be
pulled together
in a strategic way and not just a tick
box exercise
could france be heading back into a full
lockdown as germany says it will suspend
the use of the astrazeneca vaccine
over blood clot concerns saying sorry
every night
emotional evidence from the teenager who
filmed the video
of the final moment of george floyd's
life
we get reaction from mr floyd's cousin
even just hearing his voice and hearing
his moans and his cries
i wasn't able to physically look at it
but just hearing
that was was tormenting
ankle tags that detect whether criminals
have broken
drinking bans to be rolled out in
england
just after half past nine we'll be
investigating the ever-increasing
popularity of flat-faced
dogs bred to look cute but forced to
live with health problems
after today's warmth the next few days
look fine but
cooler with some night frosts and then
it looks particularly cold
as we head through easter sunday and
monday more details before half past
a very good morning to you it's taken
nearly a year but this morning a review
into racial equality in britain
commissioned by the government
after black lives matter protests will
be published in full
the findings we know so far are that the
uk
should be regarded as a model for other
white majority countries
but cannot be considered a post-racial
society now it's going to contain
24 recommendations including extending
school days to tackle disparities in
education
and dropping the phrase baim in saman
rasheed reports
with 24 recommendations for the prime
minister to ponder over
change could soon be on the way the race
and ethnic disparities commission
will later publish its landmark review
which focuses on actions to level up
inequalities
across the country the report focuses on
health
employment policing and heavily on
education
so far we know the commission has
recommended that the term
bain or bame should be scrapped
they want to see children from
disadvantaged backgrounds
to have better access to quality careers
advice
the commission also calls for the
government to develop resources
to create fairness in workplaces
and extended school days for children
from disadvantaged
working-class backgrounds the
policymakers say oh well this is what's
right
for you this is what's going to help you
you know move on in the world
but actually to engage with those people
and as i say we need to listen to what
their ambitions and aspirations are
and if they're low we need to open those
opportunities up and then we need to
give them the scaffolding to help them
get there
what's going to happen and alongside the
recommendations
the report has highlighted that children
from many ethnic communities in the uk
are often performing better than white
students in schools
a model for other white majority
countries
over the last year britain has seen huge
division in race relations
the black lives matter movement and
particularly the disproportionate impact
on ethnic minority people
during the pandemic charles has been
campaigning for the last 12 months
to level up health inequality these
things
are new pre-covered we knew about these
health inequalities
but absolutely nothing was done and so
people from
you know ethnic minority backgrounds
have been filled by the system
because if we miss this opportunity it
might take another generation and what
we're hoping is all this could be pulled
together
in a strategic way and not just a tick
box exercise that's really important
the killing of george floyd by an
american police officer
sent shockwaves right across the planet
shy
of a year on and britain finds itself at
what is undoubtedly
a critical moment this report offers an
opportunity
to address and repair long-standing
divisions
the 264-page report warns that britain
is not a post-racial society
and that outright racism still persists
in this country
this will be a stark warning to the
government the question is
whether they'll act on these
recommendations which could be the key
to tackling these long-standing issues
in saman rashid sky news
well let's talk to the housing secretary
robert generick who joins us this
morning good to see you
i mean look the headline from this
report is that britain
is an example to other white majority
countries i mean
are you a little bit surprised at that
at the tone of this report
well good morning i haven't read the
report yet because it isn't actually
published or we published
later today so i don't want to preempt
what's in it
but i have seen some of the reporting
and listen to your report this morning
and it does suggest that a good deal of
progress has been made
in the country over recent decades
particularly in important areas
like education and employment but the
prime minister commissioned this report
in the summer
precisely because he believed there was
more work
to be done and it was important for us
to do that in an evidence-based way so
we're going to consider the findings
very carefully
when we have the report and see what
further work needs to be done right
across government
i mean it's i i don't know how much
detail
the report is going to go into because
as you say we haven't seen the actual
report yet though we have had some of
the key sort of highlights this morning
i mean one of the issues is education
where they talk about
um some black and ethnic minority groups
doing better in education than white
pupils we sort of know historically
don't we that
that asian uh particularly pakistani and
indian children have have
for a long time done very well in school
black children particularly black boys
have
have lagged behind i mean you can't help
but think
have all these pupils just been lumped
into one group for this report
saying yeah they're doing very well when
some specific groups aren't
well without having read the report it's
difficult for me to comment on that
but from what i've seen it doesn't
suggest that it's lumping
groups together far from it it's taking
a more detailed
evidence-based view and concluding that
some parts of society are doing well and
getting access to the opportunities that
we all want to see for our children
and grandchildren but others are not and
those can be from a range of different
communities and what the government
wants to do
is to spread opportunity and level up
all parts of the country and so that
means
taking the steps that are required to
boost opportunity
and improve education for all children
regardless of their ethnic background
and ensure that they're getting access
to the best possible quality education
but it'll be very interesting to see
what the commission specifically
recommends i've seen
for example a suggestion that it's
recommending
an extended school day which is an idea
that's been
proposed for some time and it is an
interesting one in which the government
has already given some thought to as
part of
broader proposals to how we can bounce
back from the pandemic
and help children to catch up with lost
education
okay well you say the government wants
to take action you commissioned this
report there are 24 specific
recommendations in it i mean presumably
you then will are going to want to
implement all 24 recommendations aren't
you otherwise
what's the point of the report well the
prime minister commissioned the report
because he believed this was an
extremely important
issue for the country and that we want
to tackle this to go even further
than the good work that appears to have
been done in recent years
according to the commissioners but we'll
have to read the report carefully as i
say it hasn't been published yet
and then consider what needs to be done
but this is
a very prescient issue it's something
that we need to take action on
and the government is committed to
leveling up uniting
spreading opportunity to all parts of
the country and to all people who live
in the country
i mean tony sewell who who's the author
of this report has previously said
evidence of institutional racism in this
country
is flimsy now a lot of people
anecdotally would disagree with that
people who are affected
by racism would disagree with that it
seems
a very strange statement to be made by
someone ahead of this report being
published don't you think
well i haven't seen those remarks and
not having read the report i don't know
exactly what conclusion
they come to but from what i have seen
ahead of the publication the report
that's been been in the press this
morning
it suggests that the report does say
that there is
incidents of racism in this country
which uh is backed up by the experience
of
thousands if not millions of people
across the united kingdom but
it also appears to say that by
international standards
we're doing well as a country on the
road
to a post-racial society but
there's clearly a great deal more for us
to be doing and that's why we need
to read the report carefully and take
action
on the recommendations that it makes
again i mean just to go back to
the sort of the headline coming out of
this is that you know britain
is a model for other white majority
countries well as you say
there there's actually a huge way to go
we are not a post-racial society
according to the report it seems a bit
strange to have a headline which is
almost
giving ourselves a pass on the back you
can imagine a lot of people affected by
racism are
not going to be happy about that well
this is an independent
report so it's not produced by the
government the government commissioned
it because
we viewed these issues extremely
important and want to get the best
possible advice yeah but
it's interrupting but forgive me but
don't you think that's a bit odd
to be to to set ourselves up as an
example to others when there is so much
work to be done
well without having read the report i'm
not going to to criticize you come on
you've seen the same
you've seen the same headlines in all of
this as all of them you know
you know that you know i know you have
to read it forgive me
i know you ha i know you haven't read
the detail of the report
you know it's 300 pages long very nearly
and it isn't officially out yet but
you've seen all the headlines
the same as we have the bits that have
been released early so i mean
you're across as much of the detail as
we are
well look the this is an independent
report it's not produced by the
government
it's produced by some very respected
practitioners
from the sector they're a noted doctor a
teacher
someone from the criminal justice system
so a group of individuals with a great
deal of practical
experience they've heard evidence now
over a nine month period
and produced this report so i think it's
it's important for us to
read it and consider it carefully and
not jump to conclusions
uh if they do conclude that we've made a
great deal of progress in society then
that's
something that's positive and should be
celebrated but i doubt that they
are complacent about what needs to be
done now and the government certainly
isn't
uh there will be things that the uk as a
country is doing well by international
standards
and we see uh in other parts of the
world countries
where racial inequalities and divisions
appear to be greater than those
experienced here in the uk
but that doesn't mean there's not more
for us to do
we want to spread opportunity to all
parts of society and there's a lot of
work ahead for us as a government in
education
in employment in the criminal justice
system um and in broader society
yeah i mean just to pick one example
again and this is off the back of the
report saying we are a model to other
countries
black women four times more likely to
die in childbirth and white women
black african men 2.7 times more likely
to die of covert in the first wave
than white men less than half of black
british adults likely to have the
vaccine
i mean there is a very long way to go
well there's a lot of serious
inequalities in this country including
amongst ethnic minority communities and
that's why we're trying to tackle
each of those when you speak about
vaccine hesitancy for example
government's going to a lot of effort to
persuade all parts of
the country and all communities to take
up the vaccine
vaccine minister nadim zahawi and kemi
badanock the equalities minister
have been working now for months to to
try to persuade
and improve communication to communities
who might have concerns
and there is evidence of progress there
actually the levels of uptake of the
vaccine it is now improving all parts of
society
so that's one example of the work that
we're doing as i say we're not in any
sense complacent
we want to live in a country which is
truly post-racial where everyone has
equal opportunity
to succeed in life and this report will
no doubt play an important part
in guiding the government's work over
the course of the years ahead
can we turn to your particular brief
because obviously you you've got your
own announcements today
one of which is wanting it uh to make it
a lot easier to turn empty shops
on the high street into homes but but
within your move forward on this you
also say to attract more football to the
high street well there's not going to be
a high street left if it's all homes
well we think the high street is facing
a huge challenge the biggest challenge
probably since the second world war and
so it requires radical
solutions you can't just bury your head
in the sand at a moment like this and we
want to create
a very flexible approach the most small
business friendly approach we possibly
can and so we're creating new freedoms
to enable
small business owners who have shops
which are vacant or derelict
not being put to good use to turn them
into homes
high quality homes which enable people
of all ages to live in town
and city centres that will create a more
vibrant mixed use economy
at the centre of our communities and
help to move the high streets forwards
we're also bringing forward freedoms
actually to enable public services to be
delivered
at pace as well after the pandemic
because we want to catch up on
lost time build those hospitals and
schools and gp surgeries
across the country so again we're going
to cut red tape
ensure that those important public
buildings like new classroom blocks or
new wards to hospitals can be built much
much faster
than we used to be able to do we need a
plan
i am certainly not i'm certainly not
trying to suggest that building homes
on the high street is a bad thing in any
way shape or form
but but how does that it in and of
itself
actually help the high street in terms
of
football and shops and people getting
out to the small businesses and things
it it affects the high street's just
going to turn into a residential area
isn't it
no i don't think that's right i think
the most successful high streets before
the pandemic
were mixed-use economies there were
places where there was a mix of retail
of homes of workspaces and of leisure
and the pandemic has just magnified and
amplified those market forces and so
it'll be more important than ever that
we replicate that in other parts
of the country as well so a successful
town centre
today or in the future will be one where
there are people living
in good quality homes where you've got
offices and workspaces
where you've got leisure tourism
heritage attractions
cafes and restaurants and a good mix of
retail
the chains and and independence too and
that's what we want to try to support
to do that we need a lot of flexibility
so if you have a shop you can turn it
from
a cafe to a yoga studio to a solicitor's
office
whatever make the best possible use of
those premises
and if they turn out to be you know
difficult to let
if they're vacant if they're derelictive
as an eyesore don't let that just linger
on the high street
which is just emblematic of decline and
decay
gives the high street a bad name turn it
into good quality housing
and enable people to live there make a
life there and have more vibrancy on the
high street
so that maximum flexibility is our
approach here
uh and i think that's definitely the
right way forwards okay look just a
brief one on covid it
if you would you talked about vaccine
hesitancy earlier on i mean it's not
going to be helped by the news that
that germany has suspended the use of
astrazeneca
vaccine again down to concerns over
blood clots do we need to look at that
again over here
no we don't we're 100 confident in the
efficacy of the vaccine
that's borne out by study after study by
our own independent world-class
regulators and by recent research for
example by public health england
that's shown that thousands of people's
lives have been saved
since the start of this year alone
thanks to our vaccine
program so people should continue to go
forward get the vaccine i certainly will
when my time comes it is a safe vaccine
and the uk's vaccine rollout is saving
people's lives
right across the country every day
minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you
okay let's talk to our political
correspondent kate mccann can we look at
this
race report i mean the minister
you know not wanting to get into too
much detail on this a lot of work to be
done
he says but i said the report the fact
that headline says we are a model for
other countries
when there are still huge disparities
seems a little bit odd
yeah and i think the problem here
actually is something that you
highlighted during that interview
is that we haven't actually read the
full report yet so what we're getting
is a briefed out version with slight
kind of
sections of it but it's a weighty report
with
what seems like quite a lot of detail
now clearly robert generic hasn't
been across it hasn't read it hasn't
seen it behind the scenes it is an
independent report commissioned by the
government
but i think you know as a cabinet
minister coming on a morning program to
talk about something so
important it's clear there that there
are some gaps in how this commission
has reported so far and what the
government might do next that question
about
you know would you take on board all the
recommendations that will be fascinating
because as we know previously you know
has happened in the grenfell tower
report for example
reports that are commissioned by the
government you don't necessarily see all
of those recommendations taken on in
policy so that will be key
as will this balance between you know
clearly there are problems with
white british boys or boys with a white
man ethnic minority background ethnic
background
and educational attainment but there are
also huge problems and you highlighted
some of them
with health disparities between
different groups and it'll be
interesting to see how that report plays
out on those issues too
i just wanted to pick up on one other
thing in that interview though and it
was that point on housing and the high
street because
one of the biggest concerns coming out
of kovind 19 is going to be how high
streets around the country can recover
and i think for some independent
businesses in areas of the country where
they have
really struggled during this pandemic
thinking about getting back up on their
feet again
it will be quite concerning i think for
them to hear the housing secretary say
that vacant buildings should be turned
quite quickly into housing because what
happens if it's turned into housing
is it's very unlikely to be turned into
a shop again so once you start seeing
those units disappear
they probably won't come back okay okay
thank you
now we requested an interview with the
racial inequality report author dr tony
sewell
but our request was declined
now the trial of the man accused of
murdering george floyd has heard from
witnesses
at the scene including the 17 year old
girl whose footage originally went viral
alerting the united states and the world
to what had happened just a warning that
sally lockwood's report begins with some
footage of the moments before mr floyd's
death
which we're showing in the report as it
was central
to the evidence heard
we're learning for the first time what
was going on behind the camera
in the final moments of george floyd's
life
this viral video recorded by a 17 year
old
a police body cam capturing her in blue
next to her nine-year-old cousin in
green
after ushering her cousin into the store
to stop her seeing the distressing scene
she returned to film it her evidence
given off camera in court
i see a man on the ground terrified
scared
begging for his life it seemed like
he knew it seemed like he knew it was
over for him
she says the videos changed her life
it's been nice i stayed up
apologizing
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting in
not saving his life check it right now
an off-duty minneapolis firefighter with
emergency medical training
is heard in a separate video begging to
assist george floyd bro you're
definitely your bum bro what it is tell
me what his pulse is right now
she's now the third witness who called
the police on the police
telling the court she felt distressed
and desperate to help
i was worried that he wasn't
going to believe me and not let me
help
totally distressed were you frustrated
yes
george floyd's cousin describes the
torment for the family
reliving the final moments of his life
in court
it's honestly worse than any horror
movie i've ever seen
in my life so it's difficult
to watch um and knowing
him even just hearing his voice
and hearing his moans and his cries
i wasn't able to physically look at it
but just hearing
that was was tormenting
this trial is seeking to determine if
derek shovin's actions
were the cause of george floyd's death
what's perhaps more clear is we may not
be here now
or it not for a teenager and her mobile
phone
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis
the french president emmanuel macron is
meeting ministers today to discuss
placing the country under another
lockdown meanwhile germany says it's
going to suspend
astrazeneca jabs following fears over
blood clots let's talk to our europe
correspondent
adam parsons who's in paris for us this
morning look what
is the current situation in france adam
that is driving
emmanuel macron to look at this option
[Music]
well quite simply that the situation is
that numbers
are rising very fast that is about
infection it's about deaths but it's
also crucially about occupancy
of hospitals about emissions and what
they call the saturation of intensive
care units
and that has led to a lot of people to
say that actually now is the time
to bring in a second full
lockdown to try to stymie this life
because they're already at the
the figures that we saw in the second
wave
and heading in the wrong direction
emmanuel macron met the president john
kastek
uh yesterday he's going to meet
ministers today frankly though we don't
know when the decision will come there
was supposed there were plans for speech
by him
tonight but we don't know if that's
confirmed if he'll speak today tomorrow
next week or at any point it is an
unclear situation
and that's repeated across europe which
is dealing with this
third way and news today also from
germany
which has once again placed restrictions
on the use of the astrazeneca geoff
it's not going to be giving it now to
people uh age 60
after it's alleged links to blood clots
it is worth saying most countries have
looked at that decided
the astrazeneca job is safe to use the
uk
firmly of the mine that it doesn't need
to look again at the efficacy or safety
of the astrazeneca days
okay adam thank you well the health
secretary matt hancock has warned the
public
not to blow it after crowds were
pictured at beauty spots across england
during yesterday's hot weather
mr hancock tweeted to say let's enjoy
the sun but
let's do it safely we've come so far
don't blow it now well 4040 new covered
19 cases have been reported in the most
recent 24-hour period
56 more deaths that takes the total
number of people who've died to a
hundred and twenty six thousand
six hundred and seventy thirty
point six eight million first doses of a
vaccine have been given
the number of second doses is now
approaching four million
more than 3.7 million vulnerable people
in england will no longer have to shield
from tomorrow
people in this group are being advised
to keep social contact at very low
levels and to work from home
where possible
air raids in myanmar have driven
thousands of people across the border to
thailand
desperate to escape violence from the
military which seized power from an
elected government last month
but many have been forcibly sent back
let's talk to our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins
who jones is now from the main san leapt
village in thailand i mean we were told
weren't we only very recently that that
people were not going to be
forced back in this way siobhan what's
happening
well that's a message again that the
thai prime minister has repeated on
several occasions again today
saying no one's being forced back people
in danger who come across
these shorts here will be looked after
and people they claim who went back went
back
uh with agreement that they said that
they weren't in danger anymore and they
left with agreement that's a different
story from the one that's being told
from activists but certainly
thailand is sticking to that version of
events saying no one is being pushed
back but just to give you a view of
where i am i'm actually on the border
here so i'm standing in thailand
but if you look across the river to the
hill on the far side that's myanmar
and the buildings that you can see on
the top of it actually belonged to the
burmese army
and it's air strikes that have been
happening in this region
of uh myanmar in korean state which have
pushed many of these
refugees across the border we were told
during this week around 3000
came we understand from figures today
that there are between 200 and 500 left
in this area at least 50 today have gone
back again but the violence in myanmar
is not slowing down we're continuing to
hear reports of airstrikes as well as of
course those clashes
that we've been seeing now for almost
two months on the streets
the us secretary of state has called the
violence reprehensible
but that message doesn't seem to be
getting through to the generals in
charge
okay siobhan thank you
now time for a look at the other main
stories for you this morning and the
archbishop of canterbury justin welby
has denied suggestions
by meghan markle in her interview with
oprah that she married prince harry
three days before the official royal
wedding
speaking to an italian newspaper mr
welby said it would have been illegal
for him to sign their wedding
certificate if he knew it was false
however mr welby would not comment on
what happened at meetings with the
sussexes
before the wedding britney spears says
she cried for two weeks over the
recently released documentary on her
life and career
framing britney spears covered the
star's struggles with mental health
the media and the conservative ship that
she's under
that's where her father controls her
money effectively brittany said she'd
only watched part of the documentary
and was embarrassed about how she was
portrayed
now criminals in england who commit
alcohol-related crimes could soon have
to wear
ankle tags that can tell if they've been
drinking
sweats by correspondent ashna huranag
who's in the newsroom
how do these work ashley well stephen
every 30 minutes a sample of swell will
be taken from the person
wearing the tag and if any alcohol is
detected within that
a probation officer will be notified and
it could lead to further sanctions
it's already been trialed in wales to
much success about 95
of people that tried it 95 of the days
they had it on
it was successful in making sure they
kept sober here is one person's take on
how successful it was for them
it was quite a blessing to see something
like the attack
to like show me another path really i
just didn't care
i just didn't want to be that so i
suppose in nasa and so if i'm carrying
on the way i was
then i don't think i would be a normal i
think in my sense yeah he did save my
life
well alcohol plays a part in about a
third of violent crime something the
government is very keen to tackle here
is the home office minister kit malthus
talking about the benefits of this
scheme
don't forget these are people who've
been convicted of a crime
uh they are criminals um who would
otherwise be going to prison
uh be or be on a community sentence
and given that our success if you like
of pursuing
alcohol-related crime via that route has
been patchy should we say
um we think that this uh tagging
technology which gives us
a 95 of the time gives us a positive
result
is a win-win for everybody well critics
from substance abuse groups do criticize
this and say that it
it does appear to stigmatize the problem
for those who are wearing these tags
and doesn't solve the underlying causes
of substance abuse but the government
is as you heard seeing us as a win-win
okay
ashley thank you well this is sky news
breakfast let's see what the weather is
going to do for you today and always a
spot of sunshine our isabel good morning
to you
and you told me last week that this week
was going to be nice you've been proved
right
right it's just fab isn't it i mean the
thing is it's unusually warm i think
only about three times since the uh
met office of health records for
temperature has march reached around 24
celsius it's the warmest for 53 years
and today will be as warm as well but my
word stephen a real drop in temperature
over the coming days
let's take a look look forward
to brighter skies the weather
sponsored by qatar airways a bit of a
shock to the system shocked the system
by
uh the latter part of easter sunday and
monday with northerly winds bringing in
really quite a blast of cold air and
some wintry showers as well even right
down into the south but today
well high pressure still in charge
there's a bit more cloud in the sky a
little bit of medium-high cloud but
still very nice indeed for many parts of
england wales eastern ireland
to the north and west though which has
been very wet in recent days it's still
raining but the rain will tend to peter
out during the day it'll
be stuck for much of the day across the
northwest highlands
a finger of rain also coming down
through the west of the republic and
into northern ireland but you can see
even by lunchtime
just sinking a little further further
south across the highlands into kengorm
and then towards the central belt colder
air tucked in behind with a
really quite brisk northeast wind but
the rain does tend to peter out and all
the while
it'll continue to weaken that front as
it moves its way south otherwise though
a lovely end of the day sun setting
at about half seven and it'll be warm as
well into the low 20s
possibly 25 in the southeast but even
tomorrow
northeasterly winds and cloud with
temperatures much lower probably nearer
around the mid teens for many
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast the uk's
race report is published later this
morning and we'll be talking about the
state of racial equality
with the broadcaster emmy dabiri and the
shadow foreign secretary
lisa nandi
[Music]
so
so 12 months with each school with the
project providing a package
of training for teachers that's where
our focus is
alongside resources to enable outdoor
learning
combined with with some actual
activities with the people so it's it's
12 months in total
um in the hope that children will spend
at least two hours every week
learning outside so our project is a
flagship initiative of the government's
25-year environment
plan so there's a whole baseline of
evidence that proves that spending time
in and around nature benefits young
people's mental health and well-being
so so we were designed to test a range
of different methodologies to see
what model could be easily replicable uk
in terms of a standardized outdoor
learning program that's low cost and has
huge gains in terms of children's
resilience and more well-being
we can take whatever lesson that we are
teaching and take it outside we have
done reading comprehensions outside
math lessons outside science french
absolutely everything can be taken
outside
they become more focused and they
concentrate
more on what their learning objective is
so they know what the expectations are
when they're outside learning
and because they love it so much
behavior improves because they know that
they want to continue learning this way
and because they're engaged fully
they're you ju
you see better academic performance from
it too
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
uh morning to you now in the last few
minutes the housing
secretary robert generic told us here on
sky news that the government has
more work to do to tackle racial
inequality
it comes as a government-ordered review
says the uk
should be regarded as a model for other
white majority countries although
it cannot be considered a post-racial
society
the independent commission on race and
ethnic minorities will publish its full
report
a little bit later on this morning if
they do conclude
that we've made a great deal of progress
in society then that's something that's
positive and should be celebrated but i
doubt that they
are complacent about what needs to be
done now and the government certainly
isn't
uh there will be things that the uk as a
country is doing well by international
standards
and we see uh in other parts of the
world countries
where racial inequalities and divisions
appear to be greater than those
experienced here in the uk
but that doesn't mean there's not more
for us to do we want to
spread opportunity to all parts of
society and there's a lot of work ahead
for us as a government in education
in employment in the criminal justice
system and in broader society
let's talk to the shadow foreign
secretary lisa nandy who's uh in
westminster for us this morning good to
see you
um a model for other white majority
countries
it's it's quite a strong sort of
headline out of this report
yeah i mean i've seen the press
briefings like you have the full report
comes out this morning and obviously i
want to read it before commenting on it
in detail but
i think the briefings overnight were
very disappointing
on the one hand the report seems to
recognize that there are
huge problems that still affect um black
and minority ethnic people in this
country
every day but on the other hand it seeks
to downplay the structural
nature of some of those challenges it's
right to
recognise that progress has been made
and it's right to celebrate it
but that shouldn't in any sense mean
that we don't see the very real problems
in front of us and start to act on them
the government has had report after
report
after report including reports that
they've commissioned over recent years
they've got
all of those recommendations sitting on
their shelves what we really need to see
now is some action to actually implement
them
well in terms of action i mean the 24
recommendations we understand
in this report i mean i know you haven't
seen them all and we haven't
all seen all the full detail of the
report but sort of in principle would
you be looking to at least implement if
you were in government
implement the majority of those
recommendations
well you know i don't know what the
recommendations are but certainly
from the lamy report that we've had
previously theresa may also commissioned
a race equality audit we've had the
windrush report that was commissioned
by the home office in order to
investigate what had gone wrong
there we've got a lot of recommendations
about things that need to change in the
criminal justice system for example very
straightforward recommendations
like the um redacting information when
the police handover files to the crown
prosecution service
so that they can make race-blind
decisions
about charging it just seems to me these
are imminently sensible suggestions that
should have been implemented by now
if in a few years time if we're in
government this will be
the first thing that we legislate for in
order to make it happen
i mean one of the things which has come
out so far this morning is this idea
that you know there is still
overt racism in the uk well i mean
that's
frankly undeniable but that uh
institutional racism
uh that just isn't a lot of evidence for
that at all
don't the two to an extent at least go
hand in hand
i just think it that would be an
extraordinary finding if that is in fact
what the report
says that we we're we have a situation
in the uk
where for example black caribbean
children
are three and a half times more likely
to be excluded
from school than their white
counterparts where black children are
four times more likely to be arrested
than their white counterparts
that's not an accident that's not a
series of individual decisions that are
being made
there is an institutional problem that
has been widely recognised by the head
of the equality and human rights
commission and by successive governments
as well
and what would be a real shame and roll
back progress
is if today we ended up in a situation
where the government is seeking to down
play or deny the extent of the problem
rather than doing what it should be
doing
which is getting on the front foot and
tackling it look well thanks for talking
about that it is an important issue
could i
ask though something about your brief
today because you've got a big day ahead
today it's your first
major policy speech as a shadow of
foreign secretary where you're going to
we understand say that the foreign
policy begins at home
how does that work well for years for
decades
in fact we've had a system where we've
treated foreign policy as somehow
distinct from the needs and concerns of
people in towns across
this country but actually our
relationship with china
has far greater bearing on the
circumstances
of somebody on the factory floor earning
eight pounds 72 an hour
in stockton than any amount of high
street grants dished out
by government ministers sitting in
whitehall we've got to start taking
foreign policy seriously and treating it
as core to our domestic agenda we've got
a government that is silent
on that at the moment they claim to want
to level up the country
but they ignore the fact that jobs have
been offshored that we have a trade
system that pits
workers in different countries against
one another and depresses wages and what
i'm going to argue today
is if you want to be patriotic about the
future of this country
then you have to have a plan with the
ambition to match it
and that means not just looking at
domestic policy but looking at foreign
policy as well
okay how i mean how does that work in
terms of time then
trade in with with your your foreign
policy and say looking at
huge countries like china i mean
are you then saying we're going to
become more isolationist we're going to
we're going to not import
a lot of things from china and get them
built at home or whatever for
for a higher wage ultimately costing us
all more money
no we live in a global economy and we'll
continue to trade with countries
around the world that's an important
principle that has helped to create jobs
around the country but we have to
recognize too that
the chinese model of growth has been
based on
depressed living standards in those
countries on workers mass producing
goods
cheaply that go out and flood the market
and depressed living standards in other
parts of the world as well and we've got
to reach out and work with our allies
we've got a new
president in the white house who is
deeply concerned about this agenda and
determined to raise living standards
for the workforce in the united states
we've got to work with our allies
in order to change that model so that
we're protecting the rights of workers
we're protecting people's wages we're
protecting good skilled jobs
and the dignity of labor in our
communities in the end no amount
of wrapping yourself in a flag is going
to change the fact that this government
does not have
a patriotic vision for the people of
this country and is prepared to go out
and fight for it in the world
okay lisa and andy good to talk to you
thank you thank you
let's bring him on the inequality report
now and we can talk to
emma dabiri the academic and author of
what white people
could do next good to see you this
morning
um look in in the wake of what we've
seen of this report so far
what can white people do next
good morning um yes so the name of the
book
is um something of a provocation
it's um kind of what um
society in many ways can do next to
change the growth inequalities
that still play out along racialized
lines
it's not to say that there is absolutely
you know no
no progress in terms of in terms of
of race i don't i don't see a paradox
but i don't see a contradiction
between saying that there's progress um
in some degrees and that there are huge
inequalities and huge uh issues
with with with racism that that still
need to be addressed you know
um so to think about what the report's
saying obviously i haven't had a look at
it because this is all just like
unfolding now but from what i gather
um we know that um
wealth is stratified along racial lines
in this country so white english people
have
10 times more wealth than black africans
or than bangladeshis
we also know that inherited wealth is
the crux of social mobility
in this country so um that's something
that
that we need to look at and is and isn't
arguable
we also know that um
there hasn't been a real kind of
reckoning
with the reality of empire and
colonialism
within england you know within the uk
central
to the um colonial
uh project was the notion
of the this idea of superiority
encoded into englishness central to the
construction of the idea of
whiteness which was you know crucial to
empire building and colonialism
is again this idea of superiority until
i just
can i just can i just jump in on that
because
that sort of ties into this idea of of
of what we term institutionalized racism
the idea that
you know there's a lot of racist stuff
going on that we don't necessarily view
certainly as white people as being
necessarily racist
now this report seems to be suggesting
that although overt racism is still in
this country and
you know lots of issues need to be
addressed that institutionalized racism
isn't really at play here anymore
well i i find that difficult i find that
difficult
to believe what steps have been taken
to resolve all of the institutionalized
racism
that has been proven to exist in
countless
in countless reports i haven't even seen
you know
a truthful reckoning with the reality
of of empire and colonialism and what
that meant
and you know things to me that should be
mainstream knowledge the fact that it
was the english
that invented the concept of race
in first of all in colonial barbados um
where it was codified into law in kind
of 1661 we see the notion
of white people first advanced and
introduced and codified and that was
in order to justify the enslavement of
africans that was becoming
you know so important to the economies
of the caribbean and
eventually the the western world and it
was also
and central to this notion of a white
race that we see in that moment
and the creation of a black race that we
see in that moment is
this notion of white superiority until
that history
is grappled with is addressed is
reckoned with you know is known
even that idea of an inherent
superiority
um associated with with whiteness
is is is is present with us
um we need to have that um have that
cover yeah have a
we certainly need a conversation on that
can i just jump in and just just very
quickly because we're almost out of time
i mean this report says a lot of us
acknowledge i mean thankfully
a lot of what you call allies if you
like acknowledge that there is a lot of
work to be done
still an awful lot of work to be done
yet the report says we are an
example a model to other white majority
countries i mean
does that sit comfortably with you
um it doesn't sit comfortably with me at
all and in fact
one of the um one of the proposals that
i make in my book
it is to distinguish between um
how racism plays out and the
relationship and the dynamic between
black and white specifically to make
distinctions between
america and the uk and ireland where i
come from you know it doesn't the
dynamics are different in three
countries and i think we make a mistake
when we just import american narratives
and
apply them um all over the world but
with that being said
um one of the one of the suggestions i
make um to ireland that has a far
more recent history of um having a
a racially diverse population is not to
take its cue
from the uk is not to reproduce
the same entrenched um inequalities and
the intergenerational poverty that we
see
um you know with black and brown people
in this country
all of the issues with policing you know
it's very much
not to not to take its cue from this
country so i'd be very curious to know
what the report
says and very specifically what are the
suggestions
that um are being are being said the uk
should um other countries other majority
white countries should follow
from the uk it's common without having
seen them yeah well
i'm extremely curious we'll get the full
report i think it's about 11 30
this morning i could talk to you all
morning but we are out of time i'm
afraid i'm good to see you thanks very
much
indeed good to see you too thank you now
the illegal drug
ghb is going to be reclassified from a
category c to a category b
drug after a surge in its use now it's
similar
to the drug gbl they were involved in at
least 112 alleged offenses between
2017 and 2019 including rape sexual
assault on a child
and even attempted murder well let's
talk to
the journalist and former lgbt editor at
buzzfeed uk
patrick strudwick good to see you this
morning patrick i mean i know there is
actually quite a a link not exclusive
link but a link between
the gay community and ghb isn't there
that's certainly true and that what we
know is that
um gay men in particular are more likely
to use ghb and gbl than
people from other communities um i made
a film for channel 4 a dispatcher's film
which involved conducting the largest
ever survey of
ghb and gbr users thousands of
gay men responded to that survey and
over a quarter of those as you indicated
just a moment ago had experienced sexual
assaults
while on um qi as it's known
and over a quarter had known someone who
had died from it
and this is a very particularly
dangerous drug that in the wrong hands
can be weaponized by rapists
and predators and murderers
to their own ends and it has very
particular
health concerns for its users
it has what is known as a very large
dose response curve what that means is
just tiny incremental increases
in the dose taken by the user can have
really inflated
effects and so just one more
mill of this drug can for example be the
difference between
consciousness and unconsciousness and
unconsciousness
coma and death so forgive me for jumping
in but on
on that basis then and it does sound
very dangerous i mean would
are there any downsides to moving this
into class b from class c
there are and that's a good question
because
um certainly one of the upsides might be
that
people sort of wake up a bit to this now
and think oh this is a really serious
deal because many people just don't know
how serious it is
the problem is that and i should say
it is not by any means exclusively used
by gay men
there are lots of straight people who
use it and lots of women who have been
sexually assaulted on this drug
that being said if as the government has
said
it is reclassified to a class b drug
what it could do is dissuade people from
engaging in
emergency services from phoning 999
when either someone has collapsed at a
party
until they need an ambulance or someone
has been sexually assaulted
um because they fear that they could be
criminalized
prosecuted for having taken the drug
i mean this already exists we know this
exists you know within this survey
of thousands of people many of whom
talked about
how they were raped or uh
someone you know passed out at the party
and
that subsequently died and no one phoned
an ambulance no one phoned the police
because they were afraid of what the
police will do
i should point out here also one of the
problems
is and if the home secretary really does
get out of this
just briefly if you would um
i would recommend that she talk to the
police
about conveying a message to the public
that if they do
come forward having been sexually
assaulted on this drug they themselves
will not be prosecuted
what really what's really needed here is
public information about this drug
greater services more support and
testing
both um after a death routine toxicology
screening and in hospitals when people
are
admitted okay look patrick good to talk
to you this morning thanks very much
indeed thank you
well it is obviously a very difficult
subject it's interesting isn't it to get
that perspective on
just what the impact of moving a upper
class would could actually
do um it's not always you know it's not
as as
as black and white as you may think
anyway more on that no doubt throughout
the day but coming up next on sky news
breakfast the housing secretary tells us
the government has more work to do to
tackle racial inequality